in a melee choosing Tatsuya roseola
Georgina's baby stop
forget dinner sit on what the most
perfect - - taco Corps toriyama touch
awesome it hikes other things in the
Gila come here
I don't like it denied
bhakta children your purchasing
commodity
regardless choosing god stop emotional
cabinets with cities or candy hospital
oh my god
she's dead
you
hey youtubers happy holidays we got new
attack on Titan season 2 footage so
let's break it down Clash of the Titans
I'm going to be doing a whole bunch more
of this as we get closer to the season 2
premiere in April so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and be sure
to click that Bell to enable alerts so
you don't miss anything yeah it says
finally coming back if you guys didn't
know attack on Titan season 2 is a thing
that is happening this April which is
just a little bit after Rick and Morty's
season 3 comes back so they're just
going to be some really awesome animated
series dropping this spring so the
action of this trailer is mostly from
The Clash of the Titans arc in the manga
if you haven't been reading the manga
that's ok it's been out for a couple
years so if you have please be careful
about rampant spoilers in the comments
please use spoiler tags if you want to
talk about some of the big reveals
especially some of the stuff we see in
the trailer here there are at least two
big new Titan shifters that we see in a
couple of old favorites that have come
back let you see Arman shifts that he
can take down the armor Titan but we
also see the beast Titan for the first
time which is a completely new person
that we haven't met on the series yet
that'll be a big reveal that has
something to do with Arman's family
where you know there's the line in the
trailer where he says the Titans come
from my village it's a little ways away
from here that's the village that Arman
and his father come from so like we
haven't seen what is inside Arman's
father's basement on the TV series yet
so they'll probably reveal that there's
this big thing in the trailer about
revealing secrets to people like to talk
about revealing the secrets of the walls
that has something to do with historias
character she comes from this secret
heritage we can talk about it when we
get some more footage but it's kind of a
spoiler so I don't want to completely
give that away all I will say about that
is that historia is a very important
character we'll learn more about that in
season 2 just like Aaron's a very
important character but there are a lot
of other characters that are attached to
him like the other Titan shifters that
we haven't seen yet like the beast Titan
and this tiny little Titan here like
this right here is the smallest Titan
we've seen as they're talking about wall
rows like there's this big attack
happening on wall rows they're trying to
defend it that's part of the Clash of
the Titans arc in the manga so if you
want to read along I would recommend
that you read that part of the manga you
don't
to read the entire series but to talk
about Aaron using his hardening ability
to plug the hole in the wall we'll talk
about the wall in a second too because
there was the big reveal at the end of
the last episode in season 1 Titans in
the wall which is also part of the big
conspiracy theory that plays out over
the course of season 2 so the early
action in the trailer picks up somewhere
around soldiers dance which is right
before volume 9 number 1 so that's
really like the volume to start with for
season 2 if you want to read the manga
head and you haven't done so far it's
just called the beast Titan as you see
in this trailer like there's a ton of
bees Titan footage you see it saved me K
here so it's like oh you know not all of
the Titan shifters are bad they talk a
little bit about Annie in the trailer
she's still captive in her chrysalis
probably not going to stay that way for
a long time but you just have the idea
that there are a lot of Titan shifters
not all of them are bad some of them
want to help like Aaron and seemingly
the new Titans like the little tiny
Titan here as well as the beasts Titan
some of them like any one of bring
paradise in the walls crumbling down so
there are other big things like the
church of the walls a lot of big
mysteries they teased in season 1 it's
been so long so when we get a little bit
closer I'll start doing some more bonus
videos so if there's anything
specifically that you guys want me to
talk about or any concepts or characters
just let me know in the comments it is
so much more hardcore than season 1 even
potato girl looks like she's upped her
game big-time the title of the whole arc
is Clash of the Titans but that mostly
highlights the idea of Eren Titan
shifter fighting the other Titan
shifters and the regular Titans
themselves so I'm so happy that this is
back I cannot wait for it to get here it
looks amazing and for those of you that
are asking about the live-action attack
on Titan I would recommend just ignoring
that he was not the strongest of
adaptations and I stressed the word
adaptation as it took a lot of liberties
with the manga in the anime series like
there was a bunch of stuff that got
changed so it looks nothing like the
anime series but let me know what you
guys are most excited about just looking
at this footage just learning more about
Aaron's history learning more about his
family what was his father up to what's
really going on with the Titan shifters
I loved
conspiracy aspect of the show too
because in season one they just present
you with the very simple setup that
there are Titans they're trying to kill
everyone walking dead style who is holed
up inside this walled city you learn
about the brave serve a core characters
the ones that are trying to defend the
city from the Titans but then it gets so
much more complicated because you
learned that you know within society
there are a lot of people that are
agents of the people outside the walls
that want to bring down society the
Titans come from somewhere there are
some intelligence and a reason for why
they're trying to kill all these people
so that gets into the idea of the
leadership maybe the people you've been
defending this whole time the people who
the Titans have been trying to attack or
really the bad people if you go back far
enough because really you know you only
go back a little bit to the emergence of
the Titans they don't really explain how
society fell down they just explained
that the Titans just appeared in then
society started to fall down so people
retreated behind the walls so there's
this idea that there was a reason for
that the reason for the creation of the
Titans and why it is that they want to
get rid of the people inside the walls
so badly so everyone beware there might
be a Titan shifter amongst your group
pretending to be your friend I just love
the idea of everyone going around to
their friends during the holiday season
just you know poking them to see if they
turn into a Titan shifter but in related
news just to tide you over if you're
really looking for some cool animation
and you haven't seen it yet I would
recommend you check out Rick and Morty
now obviously this is anime Rick and
Morty is traditional western animation
but it falls like within that same
hardcore sphere of like really cool
stories that don't hold back
like it's not animation that's made for
an eight-year-old child so if you're
looking for something that's really
hardcore really visceral I would
recommend you check out Rick and Morty
which is freaking hilarious and then
rewatch some attack on titan or check
out the manga like I said volume 9 is
where season 2 is probably going to pick
up but there's a whole bunch more comic
book stuff coming this weekend so
there'll be like some fun holiday issue
comic book stuff coming later tonight
early tomorrow - so happy holidays
everyone
enjoy your break it's going to be
awesome well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the Rick and
Morty season 3 teaser and you can
click here for my breakdown of the Star
Wars rogue one Darth Vader scenes thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you